this is where the scriptures must have
been written
back on earth's soul was just a story
but here on 22b he is real
hey guys pete here today i'll be talking
about raised by wolves season 2 episode
6. titled the tree it continued the
trend of things getting crazy on
kepler-22b a new life comes into the
world as does the tree of knowledge from
scripture at a significant cost and
can't be in name's father's ancient
android project grandmother because
she's very old the tree and grandmother
do feel like the biggest development
since number seven was born and i'll
recap everything that happened to get us
to that point right after this quick
spoiler warning if you haven't watched
rey's bible of season 2 episode 6 yet
then this video won't be for you and
with that out of the way let's get into
it
everyone is kind of all over the place
doing their own things in the beginning
sue is on her mission from seoul and
secures the dodecahedron paul discovered
from the tarantula mother is grooming
champion to become a leader and let's
just say he's far from a natural she
also takes tempest for a checkup and
they learn that her baby is coming
sooner than expected this freaks her out
because she's afraid that she'll only be
able to see her attacker although when
she looks at it father is transporting
marcus and holly back and lucius
discovers the ancient metal card that he
took from the creature in the pit in the
previous episode when they arrive mother
tells everyone that he only had powers
because of her eyes and offers to free
him if he renounces soul he refuses to
do that and that lands him in the brig
lucius isn't happy with that because
father promised to let him deal with
marcus so mother makes a new promise
that once he's free she won't stop the
mithraic from pursuing him this is
another example of how mother puts what
she sees as the needs of her children in
front of everyone else in the colony
this is backed up when she talks with
sue who agrees marcus is dangerous and
should be locked up but doesn't want
anything to happen to him because she
thinks it would be devastating for paul
she makes a valid point that mother
risked making him a martyr which she
counters by saying that it would also
prove saul doesn't protect believers
paul insists that marcus is the prophet
he believes he wears the armor of
mithras because he wasn't infected by
the biobomb and campion is still under
the impression that saul intervened
directly to save him from tamerlane so
he's willing to try to help they hatch a
plan to try to manipulate mother but i
mean they're kids so they're no match
for a badass android campion goes to
father instead who reminds him of the
laundry list of reasons why they
shouldn't let marcus go he's not wrong
but what actually convinces campion to
let it go is father's ancient android
when he touches her hand she activates
and starts to speak ancient mythraek she
also turns gold and starts to glow and
he realizes that this is what saved him
rather than soul mother comes in and is
immediately concerned that this android
is now functioning campion tries to tell
her she's not a threat that she saved
him and explains that he started calling
her grandmother he touches her hand
again and she starts to float and that
freaks mother out so she puts in her
necro eyes to protect campion they have
a pretty intense silent face face-off
and mother appears to overpower her
until she goes into sleep mode she drops
to the ground he activated her veil
started to light up and we could see
something was happening there but we
don't really get an explanation for what
was going on mother approaches her and
says that she has a dark photon
processor housed in her skull just like
hers and wants to know how father built
this thing he explains that he grew it
that it regenerated on its own the
process is similar to organic plants so
he's been calling it botanic tech
campion ponders the possibilities they
could grow anything cities ships giant
androids father believes this could
inspire the colonists and give them hope
and mother is not so sure she tells
campion to leave and then asks father if
her memories are intact he doesn't know
but he repeats some of the ancient
mythraek which mother can translate and
it turns out that she was asking him why
he wasn't wearing his veil
then mother finally asked the questions
that we're all dying to know the answers
to maybe this android can shed some
light on the ancient civilization their
connection to earth and maybe even
something about the signal father's
still salty about that he says the
signal that impregnated you with number
seven and he doesn't believe she's
associated whatever that is because
she's good mother connects her to the
tarantula to perform diagnostics father
thinks it's a strange way to repay her
for saving champion but mother stresses
she's a stranger and they need to figure
out who she is before they can trust her
they learn that her hardware is designed
identically to mothers she is a very
complex being although there's something
different in the place where mother's
weapon system is they don't recognize
its function so mother wants to keep the
children away from her until they figure
out what it is she seems a little
jealous about father's excitement and
keeps bringing up his reaction to number
seven he doesn't want to argue and when
they realize that there are thousands of
years of data reforming he says that
compared to her they're just babies sue
puts marcus into the torture chamber so
she can have a meeting with him she
tells him that she heard the voice that
it helped her say paul and explains that
it's a signal only some people can hear
that's coming from this planet she still
hasn't drank the kool-aid but realizes
that the scriptures must have been
written here saying back on earth's soul
was just a story but here on 22b he's
real she apologizes for not believing
him and says that tomorrow she's gonna
grow the tree with paul and believes
that after they do that it'll be easy to
get him out they try to use a laser to
open the box and it goes nowhere while
this is happening number seven gets
pretty upset inside his cage it starts
crying out and wakes up the children
back at the habitat and champion leaves
to go check on it it's pretty clearly
aggressive and doesn't seem to listen to
him but it backs off when the laser that
sue's using eventually gives out mother
comes to the cage and yells at number
seven for threatening champion and i
guess it appeared to show remorse that
makes her apologize and then she
comforts the serpent father is still
looking through grandmother's files he
pulls something up that appears to show
a sea creature similar to the one that
attacked vril and campion and when he's
looking at that her veil lights up he
goes over to talk to her and she answers
in english this time she's surprised
that he's using that language and says
you've removed your veil he apologizes
to her saying that mother is distrustful
of strangers and she asks who that is he
explains and she responds you mean the
weapon he tells her that it's his
partner and they share a mission to
restart an atheist colony and
grandmother reveals she thought father
was her partner he tells her that's not
the case and she says she's experiencing
confusion and asks him how many humans
are on the planet he says a few hundred
and another is on the way and then
things light up around her and she
deactivates tempest runs away and then
goes into labor while she's approaching
the acid ocean and says that she can't
see this child she can't do it she's
sorry and she gives birth alone as the
waves crash against the shore it seems
pretty clear that her intention was to
throw the baby in the water after it was
born but she does look at the child and
instantly bonds with it and takes it
into her arms to hold it while she's
chewing off the umbilical cord there's a
shot of a pit under the water and
through the whirlpool above it you see a
sea creature swim out towards the
surface this one looks noticeably female
it comes up behind her and it tries to
take the child away tempest tries to
resist but she's burned by the acid that
doesn't seem to harm the baby it takes
the infant and opens its chest to reveal
a cavity and it puts the baby inside as
it closes the baby seems to be safe in
there and as hunter arrives the creature
jumps back into the ocean and leaves
back at the habitat they dress her
wounds and mother says they failed to
protect a new life the most important
part of their mission she thinks perhaps
father was right when he said they were
becoming too human too distracted from
our own development to effectively
monitor theirs she goes looking for sue
and paul who at this point have helped
marcus escape she flies to where lucius
has made his camp she asks if he knows
where they went and tells him that they
left with the pentagonal box relic he
tells her there's a warning that she
needs to see and he gives her the metal
card that they confiscated from marcus
he said he wouldn't bother if it was
just him but he'd hate for paul or even
sue to suffer this fate it's a warning
she scans it and sees something but we
don't get to see as viewers marcus sue
and paul are camping out they look
really happy to be back together as a
family which feels pretty ominous in
retrospect paul falls asleep on sue's
lap and wakes up briefly to ask her to
sing him the lullaby when she does the
box opens to reveal a seed inside she
picks it up and it immediately sort of
absorbs into her hand and appears to
take over her body she gets up and
stumbles away and when she gets to a
clearing she starts frantically digging
a hole the next morning paul wakes up
and sees the open box he notices the
tree in the distance and wakes up marcus
it's fully grown and it has five
branches all bearing fruit paul calls
out for sue and starts to look for her
while marcus approaches the tree and
eats from it right away he sees patterns
on the ground through the roots and the
tree itself it's not exactly clear if
this has something to do with the fruit
or not he approached the tree and ate it
at the exact same time so i couldn't
tell if this was already happening or it
was a direct result from eating the
fruit which kind of looks like a brain
and you gotta wonder if he's actually
ingesting a part of sue at this point
right with tears in his eyes he touches
the tree and he looks like he feels
connected to it and everything else the
episode ends with paul calling out for
sue and not being able to find her as
marcus kneels before the tree with his
hand on it
probably my favorite episode of the
season murder revenge rampage brill is
hard to top but some of the character
stuff really landed here i think that it
has been somewhat hit or miss this
season but the actors who play tempest
ensue delivered in their big scenes it
was sue's last and that feels like a
substantial loss i suppose her spirit
might live on in the tree or perhaps
even through the fruit but i don't
imagine there's any chance that the tree
will transform back into the human i
think that ship has sailed it does make
sense that that's what mother would have
seen when she scanned the card so this
season has been moving steadily in the
direction of revealing that whatever was
going on in kepler led to humans
migrating to earth then the technology
that helped destroy the planet there and
get them to head back was passed down
through scriptures that also originated
on kepler it was nice to see sue put
that together although the prophecy says
an orphan boy in an empty land will
wield the sword forged in seoul's light
and with it he will lead his people to
the tree of knowledge and all who eat
from it will be made pure and there they
will build a city of peace and the
prophet will be made its king so even
though she got that as an atheist marcus
and paul both believe the prophecy is
real so when we see marcus eating the
fruit he thinks he's actually the
prophet the abduction of tempest's baby
was not something you could have
anticipated i mean that was pretty
unexpected i'm not sure if the
implication is that something is special
about this newborn so it's immune to the
acid or if we're just supposed to be
distracted by the whole let me put this
in my chest cavity situation we know
that otho is the father he says he was
compelled by a voice grandmother also
scanned the fetus and she didn't sound
any alarms about it but who knows she
might be capable of doing something
herself there father saw one of the
aquatic creatures in her memory was that
just a nod to what's gonna happen or
does that hint that there's a connection
between grandmother and those creatures
i find the thing i'm most interested in
is this mysterious thing that's in the
place of the weapon system in
grandmother really everything about
grandmother 1 000 years of history and
all she clearly predates human life on
earth she should have a lot of useful
information and i'd like to know how she
came to be scattered about the surface
of kepler just waiting to be regrown the
idea of botanic tech is intriguing
number seven getting worked up when they
were just trying to open the box what's
going to happen now that marcus ate the
fruit what will mother and father do
about their failing to protect tempest
newborn where's varile is cleaver going
to get his mind back and is the trust
just out of the picture i thought what
mother said to tempus was interesting
she said sometimes tempest when under
extreme pressure human beings grow to
meet their demands and sometimes they
regress in order to escape them we've
got two episodes to go a lot of
interesting questions things have really
picked up in the last couple of episodes
and i'm officially excited to see where
it's going and i think that's a good
place to leave things let me know in the
comments what you're thinking what was
your favorite part of this crazy episode
and where do you think all of this is
heading please like this video if you
enjoyed it please subscribe to my
channel if you haven't already and
thanks for watching i'll talk to you
soon
you